so I'm honored to be among the
visionaries in this conference
especially since I graduated here 1983
as Alistair said 30 years ago and at the
time in computer science was a much
theoretic computer science was a much
smaller field and this is actually
forward from I think Fox 1983 and if you
see there is 8 people on the committee
and among them there is a good car in
which christos papadimitriou and I'm
told that for the conference is gonna
take place in San Francisco in a few
days there's more than 60 committee
members so the field has grown quite a
bit but when I came here I didn't
realize that the field was just filling
in its infancy and I thought that you
know my professors then there were these
grand old men recognize them there's big
cuff up there and now they're just few
of the photos that I have and I didn't
realize it I was actually they were
actually younger than I am right now
which is kind of a daunting realization
and this is a raging water okay so see
in these 13 years essentially since 1983
its billion computer science obviously
it had a remarkable journey and so it's
about computer science you know every
decade has its a theories
it says you know incredible results I
think that at that time we didn't know
that many a programming was in P prime
maladies and P there's a series of
learning and interactive post and a
harness approximation and list decoding
property testing there's lots and lots
of theories and I'm only mentioning the
ones that are more familiar and that
have happened in these last 30 years
theories results and they've had impact
as we heard yesterday on on technology
so I think in the introduction of John
Kleinberg has mentioned in his work on
web search and science the physicist
from Caltech disappointing us about how
you know seeing Shor's factoring on
quantum computer he's really motivated
his own research to go in that direction
in biology in the work of house there so
much so that Berkeley alright I think
has coined the term you patented the
computational lens or theoretical
computer science of computation on
science and
but to blame estrogen talked about a
dissonance and that's the crystal
graphic lens so when I sort of view
developments in
there are computer science left there
years you only have an hour
photographer and
since your cook your science fiction
vital signs in technology you know by
transitivity there we will see also the
effect of this cryptographic view on
science of Technology so before I start
talking about the next 30 years I just
want to sort of go back for a minute and
say that given historically some two
giants the doing fundamental work in
cryptography so Claude Shannon at the
time that he was coming up with a fear
of information theory also came up with
the theory of secrecy so that these two
papers mathematical theory of
communication and computation theory of
secrecy system and they appeared around
the same time but apparently his work on
secrecy system was classified for about
five years before they let him let him
publish it and by his own testimony
saying that he's inseparable sort of the
ideas that came up in both of these work
were inseparable foot and the motivation
went back and forth and as far as
storing is concerned we know he's the
inventor of what we call modern
computability theory and he's probably
to the public at large more known as the
breaker of the Enigma machine now what's
in common among those two guys -
information theory the other one is
talking about computation computability
theory what's common is both of their
research in cryptography a it was really
wartime research right so it's motivated
by world war ii but you just defining
what a perfect secrecy would be or
trying to break a system that's
perfectly secret in fact I think by
reading Wikipedia that they met in 1943
because of the war effort and this is
where I want to depart so their work is
motivated by you know trying to protect
communication during wartime but modern
cryptography which is sort of the
beginning of my talk it's not about it
was not a result of wartime effort it
was actually come about with the
realization that we have this amazing
digital age coming about an amazing
ability to communicate and there is some
prospect here for the economic
development and so forth and the new
cryptography needs to be reinvented to
harvest it so the court Sylvio
cryptography is not about fighting the
bad guys or athlete in mind like it's
not just about fighting the bad guys and
but I would like to think of
cryptography like you don't think about
cryptography as a theory that's
concerned with the correctness and
privacy of information and today that
the correctness is as important as the
privacy of information in the
cryptographic effort so they sort of put
three bullets which kind of will be this
event for my talk first of all
cryptography has really enabled us to do
fairly a kind of surprising abilities a
with digital information which often
when you hear about it they would seem
paradoxical in the physical world and
I'll talk about few of those second of
all which is more of the cryptographic
lens on the rest of the aware of
computer science is that it has been a
catalyst to a lot of notions and
techniques that I think have led it's
fair to say that have led to some
intellectual leaps in Cerreta computer
science and finally I believe that going
forward in the future it is really our
hope to enable taking advantage of all
this enormous data availability that we
have in connectivity while still
maintaining zhan what we call civil
liberties and
economic stability in I'll give you some
hint of why I believe this toward the
end of my talk okay so cryptography is
also a field that's done pretty well
advertising itself so these I think the
first bullet which is the surprising
abilities are probably more familiar
than anything else I will be talking
about in this talk but so let me just
flash the slide up without going through
it what I mean by surprising ability
surprising ability includes the ability
to communicate privately never meeting
in public key cryptography the ability
to somehow exchange team your tennis
league to sign a contract even though
we're in remote parts of the country and
to believe that it happens
simultaneously
edan includes being able to prove a
theorem without actually letting you
look at the proof generating a
pseudo-random numbers that look like
random numbers for any purpose that you
may desire and in other things like
playing any digital game among a party
sitting along the internet without any
referees without any deck of cards
computing on encrypted data and so forth
so there are these if you think about
these each one it's often it seems like
it can you can't do it but you can so
what is the unifying theme among all
this they seem very very different you
know playing games extension information
so randomness proving theorems so the
unifying theme in throughout all of the
script graphic development is the
presence of the adversary that's this
guy over here and not the artist but I
have direct access to the artist so so
the unifying thing the artist is amazing
so that's near so in any case the
unifying theme is that we have an
adversary now you know when I took
introduction to algorithms my first
course we talked about analysis of
algorithms like analysis of a sorting
algorithm we talked about it adversary
chosen input it's not that I haven't
seen the word adversary before but that
was for the analysis of
algorithm whereas in cryptography the
the adversary is really an integral part
of the definition of the problem so
let's say the communication system is
there's nobody listening there's really
no problem in a proof if the prover is
all you believe the claim there's no
point in actually getting convinced
about it we think about the proof is an
adversary who's trying to convince me of
the correctness of a statement but
actually has a bug and so forth so it's
an integral part of the condition of the
problem and in addition to that people
determine the quality of what I mean by
an acceptable solution so in the case
let's say of random numbers or
pseudo-random numbers if they look
random to the adversary they are as good
as anyone might may want so he both is
there to define the problem and to
determine what's acceptable or not and I
would say that actually if you think
about any kind of complex system where
there's a lot of moving parts and you
don't know how to analyze it the only
way we should be analyzing it is by
thinking that there's an adversary out
there trying to ruin the system ok and
we need to show that the system works
even in the presence of this adversary
otherwise it's not really clear how to
start analyzing what could go wrong so
what's the power of this adversary
that's going to be very important so we
will since I often it's in cryptography
or in the other applications I'm talking
about the adversary comes into play
after the system has been designed it
will make no sense to assume in advance
that here's some so restricted strategy
so he's an adaptive strategy and we will
really just assume that we have no idea
what his strategy is and moreover that
doesn't mean that he's a we think of him
as a random adversary but he will be a
worst case so his worst case we have no
assumptions about how he behaves but we
do make one assumption and then is this
adversary does not have and bound an
amount of time so he's computationally
bounded now usually that would be
polynomial time but for depending on
your application you could define that
more restricted or less restricted but
he's computationally bounded now making
this adversary computationally bounded
means that two things first of all I
claim it's realistic so if we cannot if
we cannot do something in the lifetime
of the universe that is good enough for
me
and second of all it's going to give us
great power so he's going to enlarge
essentially the range of applications
and things that we can do you know from
an impossibility to a possibility and
actually even even utilization okay so
what are let me before we start talking
about specific things what are sort of -
you know axiom source or axiomatic
notions that we use in cryptography one
of them is what we call computational
indistinguishability or what you could
call effective similarity so we say that
if the adversary that's it there are two
probability distributions those on the
on the right here and you can think of
these as the tribution Zonk a bit
strings distribution 1 and distribution
2 and say the adversary can press a
button and get a sample either from
distribution 1 or from description 2 but
it doesn't know which that happened
let's say doing by a toss of a coin
he has no eye no way to distinguish
which it is so when he sees the sample
he may have come from d1 he may have
come from d2 he cannot distinguish it
was better than you know negligible
probability winding exponential in K
morning to the decay fatigue wait this
way and that in cryptography if that's
the case we will say that as far as
we're concerned they are the same so
from the point of view of the adversary
those two probability distributions are
the same and we've applied this point of
view of indistinguishability of
probability distributions to the problem
of encryption through a number
generation even simulit annuity so after
all two people doing something in two
parts of the country are not doing it
simultaneity but effectively it's going
to look as if it is similar to name
signal tennis we will not be able to
distinguish the simultaneous from the
non simultaneous and also can apply this
to this question of correctness of
proofs not being able to distinguish
between a correct proof and a proof that
has a bug because it will be such a
small probability of that coming up
I'm just glad you're laughing okay well
we'll talk about it later let's talk
about later we'll get to it okay it's
actually not the kind of roof I'll talk
about in this lecture but there is
another notion that people have gone in
that direction there's an interesting
philosophical point of view but let's
continue right so another thing that
this enables me is to do manipulations
on probability distributions so if to
our computation distinguishable in a
second from the third and so forth we
can sort of step through these steps of
probability distributions and reach more
and more interesting conclusions so just
to make it a little bit more precise not
precise to exemplify it so what would be
these probability distributions so in
the case of encryption you could think
of one distribution is the encryption of
message m0 and the other distribution is
the encryption of message and one
actually these two sets have nothing in
common they have no common support but
if we the adversary cannot tell them
apart so as far as he can tell when he
sees the encryption of m0 encryption of
m1 they look indistinguishable to him we
will say and we will show that then such
an encryption scheme will hide all
partial information another example of
where this computation
distinguishability definition comes into
play is when you talk about randomness
so here set one is totally random K bit
strings or let's say exponentially long
strings and the pseudo-random is
you know they're not random actually
they were generated by the term mystic
program starting from a very little bit
of randomness we say if the adversary
can't tell this apart say here there's
an exponentially long string any as
random access into the string then they
are as good as random because in any
application you may use which works an
effective time you will not be able to
witness any difference since that's how
we define the computational
indistinguishability so in fact such
pseudo-random number generator is
generation is possible so what's the
second axiom I said there were two that
I would say that they are sort of
axiomatic notions and that is so in the
definition I just showed you the
adversary was sitting on the outside
right and he was looking at these two
somebody was presenting him a sample and
he was making a verdicts random
pseudo-random encryption of m0
encryption of m1
but in some of the applications we'll
think of or some of the cryptographic
work the adversary is actually part of
the system so he's not he's not really
getting a sample from the outside and
looking at it but he's actually part of
creating this sample in that case what
we will say is that essentially if this
insider view so the answer here is
talking to Alice here or or whoever her
name is so if the adversary a is an
insider and he's generating this
conversation let's say they're sending
messages back and forth they're tossing
coins if in fact this conversation is
indistinguishable again from something
that could have been simulated in the
laboratory by that same adversary he
could have sort of simulated
interactions that he is actually
participating in in the real world if
these two interactions are
indistinguishable from each other again
we would say that having participated in
it has given him nothing extra or what
we call zero knowledge and that would be
summarized that if you can simulate you
might as well stay at home okay so these
are these two is it these are these two
kind of axiomatic a notions now in my my
title of the talk is that cryptographic
Lin's so what are these developments
that I am alluding to in tavira computer
science that come from these
cryptographic results so I've listed a
few of them first of all there's sort of
the more celebrated one I'll talk about
it is this zero knowledge proof leading
to public proof systems harness
approximation all the way till actually
some extremely interesting work by
omission and on quantum interactive
experiments which I'll discuss so this
is a very famous one we have the
development of pseudo-random functions
and generators which has led to examples
of concepts which are learnable that's
already goes back to work or valentín
currency in 1983 and then more recently
of Russ Boren rorish about showing
impossibility of lower bounds by what
they call natural proofs we have this
early proof of security or of a hardcore
bit by gold rush 11 which is really the
first list decoding algorithm for
Hadamard codes and which has led to a
really a burst of developments on this
decoding algorithms read you know the
read more recent codes and up to this
was only 2005 of course Swami and our
showing explicit codes which actually
achieve linear to achieve the list
decoding bound so this is a really big
result okay in coding theory this is a
huge development in coding theory but I
I claim and I think this is a has been
checked with all the coding theorists in
question that this has started really
from this original proof of trying to
show that some something was hard
cryptographically and the proof itself
turned into an algorithm a list decoding
algorithm
another development which is much more
active these days is developing on those
unluckily decodable codes so very early
days I think that actually microwaving
was visiting Emmanuel Blum here at
Berkeley and he came up with this idea
of oblivious transfer the idea somehow I
can transfer you information and now I
don't know what I'm transferring sounds
like a bizarre activity but turns out to
be very fundamental and in any case that
has led to something called private
information retrieval and in turn two
algorithms on locally decodable codes
what does that mean that's a code okay
so you could take a message and you
encode it for error correcting code such
that you can recover you know let's say
the ice bit of the original message only
by looking at a few bits rather than
having to look at the entire codeword
and you know very important for
applications very strong results at this
point I can click on going let me just
do the last one and that is that often
it's not the notions but it's a the
techniques okay that have been very
useful so say techniques for proving an
average case hardness usually work this
way you wanted to map any worst case
instance to an average case instance and
what that means really is that there are
no worst-case instances everything you
know is is it's an is it hard instance
every average instance is hard but the
technique really shows you how to take
any problem and map it to some a random
sample in in a way in a sense and in
fact it has the direct link to properly
testing of the day where instead of
looking at an entire input you can sort
of sample it at places and make
conclusions from these global from these
local checks about a global property and
I haven't mentioned here you know the
the worker number theory which came from
apparently the people trying to break
RSA in quantum or other ways a which has
been very inspirational as a motivation
to work on these problems so of course
I'm not going to talk about all of these
a I will talk about that left thread
essentially mostly because it's going to
bring me up to current day
okay so I said don't tell me what time
it is but tell me what time it is 20
minutes okay well this is where my stock
talk starts really but I can speak
faster okay so so we're gonna talk about
a thorough knowledge proves and sort of
how where they are today so what we're
talking about poof's
okay so proofs you know we're so
obsessed with originality and the
creative process and these grand old
provers that we forget we have forgotten
often in mathematics that is actually
somebody else there and that's the
verifier so the prover here is one party
but we're going to focus on how hard it
is to verify this illustrious what did
Maria say a hundred pages two hundred
fifty pages so we're going to focus on
how difficult it is to verify a proof
and we will focus on atomic
computational point of view so this
verify is going to let's say that he
works in polynomial time in the claim
sides that's as much time that he has to
check whatever proved you provide him so
the canonical proof is let's look at an
example let's say this sum equation and
then the prover says listen uh I have I
have solved this equation and that's
it's a difficult equation to solve we're
not gonna worry at all how much time the
prover takes he's infinitely power and
he does not concern me all concerns me
is how much time it takes to check the
proof you know we will break we could
bring this down to earth but this is the
theory visions from what I've seen
yesterday we don't have to be down on
earth
it could be flying with ducks in the air
so so so we care about verifier here
over Bob
how does she convince him she can solve
the equation she gives him a solution
it's very simple right she says X 1 is
equal to 0 X 2 is equal to 1 and so
forth and that's trivial
then he can plug it into the equation
checks it works out he says I accept you
have convinced me now what has happened
here is that after the interaction Bob
he believes the equation is satisfiable
or because he got the solution but he
actually knows also a particular
solution this equation may have many
solutions he knows now one which he did
not know before and the question is and
that's makes sense right all proofs are
like that you write them in a book now
or you back to you and assuming that
you're you can understand my handwriting
you can prove to someone else and so
forth ok but the question is from a
cryptographic point of view that's
really we don't want to give more than
we should so is there any other way can
I convince you in any other way but
giving you the solution to the equation
and there is and and essentially there
if we had to have a caption we would say
I'm not going to give you the solution
but I will prove to you that I wanted if
I wanted to I could okay so I'm gonna
convince you I could give it to you but
I'm not giving it to you ok so how is
that play out in the case of the
equations I so first of all how am I
gonna do this we're gonna have a deviate
from the idea of it the classic approver
writing a textbook
we're gonna need coin tossing and we're
going to need interaction between the
Poobah has to be present in order to
convince me of that we're gonna have to
talk back and forth and at the end I
will believe but I will not know the
solution to the equation so this is the
only technical slide in the talk ok
yes
I was especially big the equation is
just okay here is a particular equation
okay let's look at a particular equation
alright what I meant by an equation is
just to say that any proof I can think
of it is that you tell me what the
length of the proof is it's every bit in
it you can think of as a variable and
you know essentially an assignment to
those variables is an instantiation of
the proof a classical proof okay but
let's look at a particular equation to
see this example so the particularly
equation is that the prover what
integers now they are integers so the
particularly equation is that he wants
to convince you that Y is equal to x
squared okay very simple equation mod n
where n is a heart is a number and if
then n is a number which is hard to
factor for the verifier this is a
difficult equation to solve it's as
difficult actually as factoring in but
this proved ER is all powerful you know
this Alice she's something and she has
proved she has solved this equation now
she wants to tell Bob the solution but
she doesn't really I mean she wants to
tell him that she could tell him the
solution how could she do that now this
system is really very typical of any
zero knowledge proof the idea is the
following she will pick a random number
there did you see that flip it's quite
something okay so she flips around the
number R and using this R she comes up
with two equations one equation is R
squared mod in the second equation is
the original y times R squared morning
so now that these two random equation
each one on its own is completely random
has nothing to do with the original
equation however if you solve solutions
for both of them so you knew R and you
know square root of of Z and it's bored
of Z times y of course you can construct
the square root to the original equation
the thing is that she's not going to
give him the solution to both equations
she says look here's Z and is Z times y
I could solve both of them but I'm not
going to because I don't want to give
you the entire proof you choose which
one it's up to you
obviously if she can solve both no
matter which one he's gonna ask for she
can answer but if she cannot solve both
okay she can solve one or the other then
he might if he asked the wrong one she
doesn't know how to solve he will catch
her with mistake
so the Bob here you know he's confused
he says what am I gonna do or how am I
gonna figure this out and we say best
strategy is choose at random it's the
best you can do flip a coin ask her for
either to solve one or two and see if
she succeeds and in fact if she he will
accept the claim that the first equation
is solvable if and only if she's able to
so to answer his question so note would
happen here I claim that if in fact
Alice this equation was solvable else
can answer any equation 100% of the time
she can answer his questions but if the
equation was not solvable then the
probability he's gonna catch her based
on his coins she has nothing to do with
it is greater equal than 1/2 because it
was a probability he will land on the
equation she cannot solve so in a sense
what are we doing here we're saying that
he can prove a correct theorem and he
can get away and he can we will be
caught in moving an incorrect theorem
with probability 1/2 not a very good
probability but if we repeat this we can
make it exponentially small just do this
again and again until it disappears okay
now why why did we do such an effort I
mean wasn't it easier for provers just
to give Alice the solution to the
equation because essentially 1 - but
well yes 1 - thank you otherwise not too
good why did we do this because at the
end Alice should be convinced a Bob
should be convinced with a really
overwhelming probability that she didn't
cheat him but what has he gotten he's
gotten solutions to random equations
completely useless could have generated
it on his own in the laboratory and
stayed home didn't have to go talk to
Alice okay he did have to talk to her
right because she actually did convince
him of something but nothing else so
this is really uh what's what's it
what's called zero knowledge interactive
proof
as you said we are changing here the
notion when I say proof you know when I
used when I did say this thirty years
ago people in the math department would
like be willing to stone us but now less
so with all the prizes and everything
I'm you know but seriously speaking we
don't call it a proof we call it
Interactive proof okay so we're saying
it's a process of convincing a
distrustful adversary that has both
completeness and soundness if it's
correct I will convince you if it's
incorrect you I will not convince you so
with overwhelming probability you will
catch me and in a day and ultimately
we're saying that's what any proof
should be okay
in addition it has the zero knowledge
feature and the zero knowledge feature
has been you know extremely useful I
will not talk about that here mostly due
to a general hour its generality if you
improved by goldrock McCallion witnessin
showing that the example I gave which
used no assumptions or anything can
actually be true about any language any
classical proof can be turned into zero
knowledge proof if in addition you want
to be willing to assume that one-way
functions exist so I thought I've heard
everything about the or knowledge but
then Boris gave this talk did you see
this down here zero knowledge and
nuclear disarmament amazingly enough
there's a paper by boss Barak with
Glasser and Goldstone for two physicists
in Princeton which have used the concept
of zero knowledge to come up with a
scheme how you can this disarm a nuclear
warhead without actually looking at its
design and it's it's kind of fascinating
because I can actually understand that
paper I mean I don't understand the
physics but the method is very similar
to what we do for digital information
okay what is this a catalyst for so this
is really well known you know and in
some sense I it's like I hope there's
some people here haven't seen it before
but what has this been catalyst for so
it has been if you think about it the
catalytic understanding here is that you
can decouple the correctness of the
proof from actually the knowledge
checking the correctness from the
knowledge of the proof that these are
not synonym to each other
and once you make that decoupling it
really means that you can start asking
you questions he says oh if that's the
case I can ask new questions about the
nature of a proof it could be like maybe
I can prove harder statements that I
could originally maybe I could prove
things more efficiently maybe there are
the proof systems altogether I could
look at if it's not about writing in a
book other systems may make sense and in
fact these are the kind of questions
that have been asked and actually
answered in the last 25 years leading up
to some current research on cloud
computing okay so here's we continue so
can we in fact prove more than we could
from a classical proof so that equation
now I hope that you understand so in
some sense you think of these barrells
as boolean
we can definitely convince a verify it's
satisfied just by giving him the
assignment to the variables but how
about this can we do things like
convincing that there are no assignments
how do we do that
I mean he we can't cycle through all
that we'll take too much time can we
convince him that's the current P class
can we convince him that there are
actually exactly two to the 100 minus 13
solutions again it seems like a
tremendously more difficult thing to do
or can we even convince him something
with alternation of quantifiers P space
I won't get into what that means so
classically we don't know how to do that
but with an interactive proof he came as
a really a fantastic surprise when
fourtner Karloff London Nissan and they
fold by Shamir showed you can
so using this mechanizing of the
verifier tossing a coins going back and
forth okay even forget to say or
knowledge just we want to prove these
statements it is possible to prove P
space type of equations that is I can
show you that there's zero solution
exact number of solution and it's
actually exactly equal what you can
prove through this interactive mechanism
is what is in P space now
great that seems like a very good story
and a good place to stop however we're
not satisfied I mean in general we are
dissatisfied a lot I think but in any
case because all these adversaries
roaming around but the next kind of
national question is that another way to
prove theorems okay so we've got this
interaction he's got a very far what
else can be done and this is a here is
another model together with avi and
McKibben or and Joe Killian when I was
visiting Ashley sabbatical in Israel and
the question is okay you know what what
can we do what we would like to do so
remember I had that zero knowledge
theorem which if one-way functions
existed everything is in zero knowledge
so we don't like this assumption if one
way function exists like it is some
other way you can be convinced of a
statement we in zero knowledge making no
assumptions whatsoever
so we're saying how about adding another
proof er no that seems really kills
right the food is infinitely powerful I
never put any restriction on him why is
it going to help to have two infinitely
powerful provers I mean two one what
difference does it make the point is
going to be that they don't talk to each
other so this is very much like those
people like to see law and order
you know those investigators they love
it when they have two suspects not than
one right because when they have two
suspects they put them in a room they
ask him tricky questions and then BAM
they catch an inconsistency okay so
these two provers are going to be
sitting in different rooms the Avera is
going to interrogate them and the hope
is that if they deviate he can check
them by being inconsistent it turns out
that this is the next sort of catalytic
understand sort of kind of leap that by
checking consistency is incredibly
powerful so why is it so powerful and so
first of all we can we showed in fact
that you don't need assumptions you
could do zero knowledge perfectly
unconditionally for anything in NP so
two people closed in a room because they
have to be careful not to be caught they
will tell you the information in such a
way that you can verify it and they've
really given you you know zero knowledge
okay even without any assumptions but
even more fascinating than that
bye-bye lord fourtner and lon very
quickly after that IP equal to p space
result have shown that the to prove errs
are more powerful it seemingly than one
so not only that they can actually
convince this poor polar on time
verifier of non-deterministic
exponential time statement so we went
from NP classically to non-deterministic
exponential time with these two guys
somehow this an ability to to check
whether two proofs are could to poopers
are consistent gives you incredible
power and where here's an example kind
of to explain that so let's say there's
a system of equations so these are both
an equation so these equations over is
GF 2 in linear equations and they're not
if there's no assignment satisfies all
of them ok because if there was we could
find it by Gaussian elimination but it
turns out to be a very difficult problem
to tell whether let's say 99% of these
equations are satisfied or more or or
just 51% so and if you had a single
program what do you do he claims more
than 99% you say ok give me the solution
to the equation I check it it's more
than 99% I'm happy okay but it's not a
communication you have to give me the
solution to all of the equations if you
have to okay here's another strategy
essentially the verifier chooses a
random equation one of the many
equations ok he sends that equation to
one Pulver says hey give me the
assignment to those three variables then
he chooses one of those three variables
either X 1 X 4 X 7 at random at say X 7
sends it to the other prober and he says
hey what's X 7
now if in fact there was a solution that
satisfy 99% of the equations no problem
they just answer according to that
solution but if there isn't one okay
when I ask the second guy 4 X 7 Trudy
could say zero should he say one zero
satisfy some equations 1 satisfies
another equation he he better tell me
the best he can and if the best he can
is less than this 99% or let's say like
51% then I will catch him so this is
just an intuition why this enables me to
reduce communication dramatically
because originally they had to give me a
solution to everything
now I've asked him really for four bits
of information three bits for one the
assignment to those three variables one
bit from the other and this can be
proved really to work so it's not just a
toy example
so you're on hostile you have to I have
an algorithm whose pictures show up so
at the end of the talk quiz if you have
no other questions you can answer that
one hey so any case you're on huh stud
showed that this in fact is a multi a -
proof interactive proof with good
soundness and good completeness you can
prove cracks theorems you cannot prove
incorrect
and this has led to really if you think
about the crux of that idea is what
underlies the PCP theorem it says that
any theorem in NP can be proved by
looking at constant number any a
constant number of bits from these two
approvers and checking a consistency and
as you know it's led to as far you know
really far-reaching consequences to
showing hardness approximation which can
be done in a sense you can see a lot of
these proofs is analyzing the grab the
game graph there's a game here between
these two provers and the verifier and
if you look at this game graph and
analyze it you could see that winning in
this game can be translated to having
let's say a large clique in this graph
and so forth and if you are talking
about what is the probability of winning
that turns into asking about what is the
size of the largest graph oh how good
can you approximate it but we won't go
there instead this is all ends in 1990
again but in a pair something that
happens in a Berkeley campus so we kind
of bring it to today so in a very in
really a parallel universe as far as I'm
concerned people have been talking about
quantum provers okay so I think quantum
so they took those two where Alice's
close and blocked away
they now have quantum power and also the
verifiers quantum power and apparently
there's been a long line of work
and it has been shown somewhat
disappointingly
I think that a
doesn't add the mini power so where is
it seems like these bqp algorithms can
factor or perform computations we don't
know how to do on a classical computer
once you go to this proof question and
let the provers which we're all powerful
also be quantum okay that does not add
anything okay so same thing that can
done interactively can be done with
classical provers can be done with
quantum computers but then a fascinating
question was asked by the waiter owner
of a Michael Biehn or and a man and the
question is the following
ok let's forget the provers let's go
back down to earth I guess earth in the
physics department and that is let's
let's talk about qbp bqp so there is
these guys are not provers they're not
all-powerful they're just quantum
computers that run in polynomial time
and if in fact these qbp algorithms are
computing things which we can't verify
classically let's say they're not in NP
okay how do we even check that so they
somebody comes he says I got the
computers and they work how do I know I
mean how do we do the classical
experiment where you know we kind of
predict what the result is then we can
verify we can't predict it we don't know
how to compute it ourselves that's what
we need the quantum for so it seems to
be a problem so the question that they
asked was can interaction help you can a
classical experimentalist with classical
verify or talk to these polynomial time
quantum computers and get convinced that
in fact they are quantum that they did
compute what they claimed they did okay
they didn't manage to do it with a
single prover but this Berkeley campus
this recent result I called hunger and
was in English shows that if they have
two quantum computers and you put them
in separate room so you got two by two I
understand even when it's pretty
expensive in any case you buy two you
separate them so that it cannot
communicate with each other but they are
entangled
so you add you entanglement to the model
so they get entangled before you
separate them
they can convince a classical verifier
that they have done the computation they
claim so that is kind of amazing because
it's so it I think it's a beautiful idea
of a new way to conduct experiments so
rather than the old scientific paradigm
of you know predict verifying predicting
it's looking for an inconsistency so if
there is no inconsistency
I will accept and though they will prove
is that if the theorem is false okay and
the quantum computation was not done
there will be an inconsistency that you
will be able to catch in polynomial time
okay so it's really I think you know
amazing so no okay they aim all right so
where are we gone we started with these
polynomial time guys okay was not really
polynomial but Paulo no time Bob and
Alice he couldn't think of it as
polynomial with a secret doing things in
firm a trying to prove theorems hiding
information we ended up with these
quantum polynomial time guys trying to
convince a verifier that they are
actually quantum ok but meanwhile that
we've been doing all this you know the
world of computing you know going to
these fears of is evolved ok so this
gives brings me to the last part of my
talk so used to be that we had a big
computer and there was you know a little
cloud which was really cloud in the sky
but essentially what's happened now is
that you know computers are getting
smaller we all have these iPhones when I
was asked to close it was going to show
it so we all have these very very small
mobile devices they don't have
necessarily room to store all our data
and computation and meanwhile the cloud
has been growing and we're told that in
fact in the future which is like it
would be like opening the water faucet
right and the water is going to come out
you know all the computational resources
are going to come out from the cloud ok
so what does it have so if you think
about today today you know I put my
powerpoints on des and the cloud so make
sure that I don't lose them when I come
to give the talk and you might put some
other documents in the cloud but in the
future you know we will put all our
personal information there in fact it
will be the only place the personal
information will be sitting including
sort of who we are so let's say our DNA
DNA information and so forth so all our
data is going to migrate to the cloud
and in fact it will be the only place it
sits now what about computation again
we're gonna have these very simple
devices and they're not going to be able
to do all the computations we want on
that data in the cloud so also the
computation is gonna be done in the
cloud it's really fantastic so house
that was talking about sharing of
information there's been fantastic
possibilities here right all this stuff
is gonna be sitting the clown brave new
world enormous potential and
globalization of knowledge you know we
have all this knowledge out there we
could make computing on it we can deduce
cancer treatments and so forth but there
is a problem here and the problem is
that we have relinquished all control
right so right now when you put things
in Dropbox I mean I don't know what you
I just put it there you know that I have
all these MIT students working Dropbox
they could look at whatever I write
there anytime they want okay
and I am not worried I should be worried
think about all our computing power is
there or data is there can we take
advantage of this without relinquishing
control that seems totally a
cryptographic challenge and in fact
let's talk about these challenge and
what we're doing about it today and that
will be the end of my talk so challenge
one challenge one is forget about
privacy okay
privacy you know we'll we'll forget
about that for a minute but why do we
even trust this cloud is computing
correctly okay why should we even trust
that well what we won't trust it we want
to verify that so this is what we call
delegating computation we've given our
cloud there a ability to compute for us
but we now we want to trust but check
what they give us back ok and that seems
to be very close to what we've been
talking about right proofs except these
days what what I'm suggesting here or
what people have suggested here is the
cloud is going to not just compute but
it compute
improve okay so proving is going to be
an integral part of computing in the
cloud every computation is going to be
accompanied with some kind of a proof
that the computation was done correctly
now obviously this proof it's got to be
the case that checking this proof has
got to have to be much much faster than
computing because otherwise what did I
need the cloud for okay so somehow there
has to be the case the cloud is doing a
lot of work my checking has to be
extremely fast excellent
didn't we just show that pspace you know
we can do incredible computations the
prove it could be paint the piece based
computation and the verify just I have
to be polynomial time so it seems like
we've solved the problem with
interactive proofs the problem here is
so what's the language your interactive
process is that X is equal f of X is
equal to Y the problem is that if you
really didn't look at those proofs what
happens there is they work wonderfully
when there's a huge gap between P space
and polynomial time but if actually the
computation you're doing was in
polynomial time to begin with they don't
work so well in particular this theorem
says that if your algorithm that the
cloud is doing took s space say then he
will take the prover to to the
polynomial in s time to prove you the
correctness of a statement now this
proved err he's the cloud he's powerful
he does not have exponential amount of
time okay so the challenge now is how do
we actually prove maybe using
interactive proofs or some other to
prove approves or whatever in such a way
so we want to delegate the proof of the
result of a polynomial time computation
where the prover doesn't work much more
than it took him to compute okay so he
has to be really relatively efficient to
his computation and this guy has to be
super efficient not polynomial time he
should be very linear time maybe even
less than linear time so that's the
question can you use this whole
interaction with his Bo powerful prover
to actually do this specific concrete
task which is verify computations which
are done in the cloud it's a very very
active research area so I summarized in
a table
realize I don't have time to go through
each result and if you there's really
tons of papers here and I have only
referenced three so why did I choose
these three they really to see that
there are different models with people
look at one model is just interactive
proof okay so no assumptions on on the
prover you're saying any strategy of the
prover I trust after we'd go through the
interactive proof and in such a case we
can in fact show that as long as the
circuit that's computing the program has
depth D we could be convinced in D
rounds of communication and taking
slightly less more than linear time to
verify okay then if you're willing to
make computational assumptions like I
won't exactly go into what they are you
can do much better than that so you can
take any toy machine of time T this is a
new result by alkali on on rosin and run
in in Ron rose bloom they are
indistinguishable the bottoms and not
really but for the purpose of this line
a and they show the fake any touring
machine that runs in time T then
approver can work in time essentially a
little bit more than T and convince a
verify who just runs in quasi linear
time okay and lock in polynomial
logarithmic of T so verifying is really
log of computing that it was computed
correctly and then you get another if
you make sort of stronger assumptions
you can actually talk about
non-deterministic time and not just Tory
machine model by random access model
which is much more the way that we
actually compute and in fact
so this is guy and yell and in fact
there's another line of work which is a
victor CERN guy and and Celine where
they said you know what these days who
is time even to look at X we're talking
about Big Data X is this huge amount of
data
verify doesn't have time to look at the
whole thing so what we want that say is
a sub linear algorithm so we want to be
able to check computation without even
verify looking at the input of course we
were not going to get exact answers we
will get what we call approximate
answers I won't which means that they're
close to exact in some formal sense and
they can show how to do that as well in
this new work which is gonna appear in
stock I understand now this last bullet
just says that all this is not just
theory turns out that there is actually
practical efforts ok so there are
programmers we know how to write
programs and are writing programs to
take these results and translate them to
real systems there's a paper in crypto
this year that shows how to implement an
implementation how do you prove the
results of C programs and that needs the
RAM model so it's very interesting to
see how far this will go and when it
will make I mean something will make its
way into real systems and the question
is how long that's going to take all
right so challenge to my last challenge
challenge 2 is privacy
after all this demo knowledge the point
why did introduced it I wanted to prove
your theorem so that you believe it but
you find out nothing else ok now in the
cloud I'm putting on my data there
that's it you know I want the cloud
compute for me but what about the
privacy of my data so encryption you
know right we need and everything's
gonna be encrypted of course as soon as
everything is encrypted how is the curve
gonna do the computation he wants to
compute f of X but X is encrypted so
what we need is to add an encryption
scheme where there's both privacy and
functionality somehow given a of X we
can compute on X without actually
knowing what it is
and that's exactly the next challenge
encryption comes back encryption of the
result returns right somehow the cloud
is able to compute on X without
decrypting and finding out what it is so
now it turns out that this question
whether this is doable it has a name
it's called fully homomorphic encryption
is it possible for any computation F to
do this is there an encryption scheme
that supports that so this question was
asked by reversed Adelman and they did
their two sauce thirty years ago it's
more than thirty years a thirty five
years ago thirty five years ago and
apparently when they asked it at least
that's what Adelman claims I just met
him a couple days ago is it was to say
that this is impossible but you know
cryptography is a way to surprise us
often these things that seem to be
impossible actually a are possible and
there was this famous result by Craig
Gentry from Stanford who showed how to
do this so he exhibited a method based
on some assumptions on difficulty of
some promise analysis to do this folio
morphic encryption and some of this
impossible seeming task okay which was
first shown possible on the same
assumption 2009 it since I've had sort
of lots of work and the the most
efficient and also based on much weaker
assumptions is by broker schemes like oh
it's Nathan in 2011 so wonderful we can
compute on encrypted data are we done
you know of course so this is a Heil -
fantastic tool for computing unencrypted
data but does it really solve everything
we want to solve and I wouldn't ask that
question I am if I didn't have an answer
and so I'm claimed no it is not enough
ok why is it not enough what are some
things we might want to do that we
cannot do with full morphic encryption
so I claim that this is not enough if
this cloud which we can think of the
evaluator of the function needs to know
the result ok so we need to know the
result of the computation a and this
does not give it to me right
so for morphic encryption I send
encrypted data I get back encrypted
result so the errors are going the wrong
way
a right this last error should go the
whole thing is the wrong way yeah so
just switch over in your mind and the
errors are the other way so I'm sending
encrypted data I'm getting back
encrypted result but the cloud might
need to actually know the result
encrypted result is not good enough why
would that be the case so here are three
examples where that would be necessary
so first example is let's say that this
this is the mobile device over there so
let's say that this guy he hasn't
quipped everybody sends him encrypted
email how many people in this audience
use encrypted email wow that's more than
my category class at MIT ok in any case
let's say in the future we all use
encrypted email ok oh you didn't come to
me email and we want to be able to run
it through a spam filter so that the
ones who are spam will be junked and we
never have to look at them ok so that so
we can let the cloud ask me to run our
spam filter on us the thing is wonderful
they run the spam filter on an encrypted
data and they found out that this is
spam but they didn't they found
encrypted the word spam so now they give
it to me so that I can decrypt and find
out it's spam what's the point
I want the cloud to do the work ok so we
want the spam filter to be able to tell
that this email was spam even though he
didn't wasn't able to read it so I want
to be able to know the result of the
computation which is this
must be junked okay now how do we do
that well we could give this Pam the key
the secret key but then he could read
all my data but that's not a good idea
we could talk we could have the spam
field to talk to me but I don't want to
talk to him I don't wanna write that's
why I don't wanna read this Pam so they
will not work what we need really is a
way to be able to find out the result of
the computation not without decrypting
the message what's another thing so you
know the cameras are everywhere okay so
there's surveillance cameras everywhere
you go okay and you know it's a little
bit of a problem right because we need
these cameras but on the other hand you
know how idea of privacy and sort of
civil liberties in contradiction with
this so suppose in the future there was
a law that all surveillance cameras
would only produce encrypted photos okay
but then what's the point of having the
camera again with okay well the point is
wouldn't be nice if we could go to a
suspect database and evaluate the filter
to see whether in that photo there is a
suspect without actually looking at the
photo all we want to know is when there
is a suspect in there that we've tagged
that photograph okay and maybe even who
the suspect is how do we do it so I want
to run through this thing at the end I
want to say I want to have the result I
want to say yes no there's a suspect in
this picture or not without having to
look at the picture okay
what's the third example that's possible
so again we want to know he appears in
the scene without seeing the picture a
third example is motivated by the talk
of Housley yesterday say there's a
medical he says that people don't to
share their data ok and that's a problem
because we need sharing of data now
suppose we want to conduct a medical
study on this confidential medical
information so there's a laboratory they
have all the data encrypted ok there
might be willing to share their data a
or less but not fully they want to so
could it wouldn't it be nice if they
would give you the data in such a way
that you could run your medical study
that they approved but that's it so you
would find out the results of medical
study and then maybe decide to do some
new drug treatment but you haven't find
out my entire medical profile okay so
all the sounds again very futuristic how
can I encrypt and still let you have the
ability to compute something but not
everything if you think about zero
knowledge in some sense what did we do
there I want you to convince you the
correctness of a proof but giving you
nothing now I want to gave you the
result of a computation but give you
nothing else ok so it turns out ok there
is this amazing tool called functional
encryption what's functional encryption
oh I like the name filterable decryption
because we want to sort of well to be
allowed to decrypt through a filter ok
and this is a long line of work but I
think that this exact formulation
appeared in a paper by Bonilla high in
waters in 2011 so what this system does
is the following I'm still I'm still
sending my encrypted data ok but I want
you to be able to run some computations
on X which you will find out what the
result of they could be a profiling
they could be medical study they could
be whatever the idea is then I they
suggest is maybe it's possible for me to
give you a special key not a key that
will able to decrypt the entire data
just the key s K sub F they will able
you to run F on X so at the end you'll
find out the result of f of X but
nothing else ok so someone for every
function let's say there would be a
special key then
Able's you know and that computation
find out that result about X but nothing
else okay
so incredible question how would you
even define security here again you
would use sort of simulation type
argument that is you want to say that
this cloud he gets this secret kid
enables in to do the computation he can
do that but nothing else so as far as
the cloud is concerned whether he sees
you encrypted data or not he's in the
same situation and so they ask the
question whether it's possible there's
been a really long line of work showing
that it's possible for particular kind
of functions or it's possible if you are
willing for the encryptions to be
extremely large which kind of makes it
not that interesting because it means
that the mobile person and the cloud
work at the same amount which was not
the reason why we're going to cloud to
begin with but this is my last slide
really there's a paper in in stock that
even Luca Papa is going to describe
which is a new functional encryption
scheme or filterable decryption as I
like to call it that can solve these
problems so you can show how to do this
for any polynomial time function f so
how to give you the ability to compute
it and the encryption scheme at the end
has ciphertext which are what we call
xvi so they're short if the size of the
computation is s and the depth is d is
the size D those are already technical
details but it means that we can solve
the examples that I discuss now we are
not done there tons I mean I am done
don't worry but but there are many many
more questions that we ask and some of
them we can solve some of them people
are still working on for example how
they talked about the fact that we could
be able to talk we want to share data
across providers across the world so in
the language here would be encrypted
data by different keys doing sort of
aggregate type of computations all this
very much subject of active research
and what does that mean let's go back to
the beginning the title of my talk is
the cryptographic lens so there's sort
of two takeaway messages first of all is
that I think that our expectation for
what is possible for digital privacy
it's very important it really should not
be bound to what we kind of experience
in the physical world so with digital
information you can do pretty amazing
things which we we have to sort of free
ourselves from thinking about what can
be done physically and second of all you
know I think it's more fascinating
question maybe for people it's sort of
younger in the audience or sort of
graduate students is okay we're doing
this research there are new methods so
the encryption now is based on methods
from lattices not from number theory it
is computing on this representation of
data encrypted form how are these
techniques and notions affect maybe a
complexity theory of tomorrow and I'm
sure they will have somebody ideas even
but I think it's I said history tells us
anything for the future it's going to be
interesting
thank you
you